welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is bonus day
three and we're gonna learn from the
fifth
richest person on the planet at the time
of this recording with a net worth of
122.2
billion dollars mr mark zuckerberg
to me entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies
and you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who i've met
care deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create
and often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company
right and you know that's how i think
about um
you know my connection to to all of us
here is
you know i was getting started i um and
i wanted i cared deeply about giving
everyone
uh a voice right and giving people the
tools to share everything that they
cared about and
uh bringing a community together and you
know it started small and in one
university
and i didn't think it was going to be a
company at the time as a matter of fact
i was pretty convinced that at some
point someone would build
something like this for the world but
you know i thought that would be some
other company that you know already had
thousands of engineers and
was used to building stuff for hundreds
of millions of people around the world
and
you know what ended up happening was um
you know that no one built it right so
we just kind of kept on going right i
mean
people said it each step along the way
um
you know what you're doing all right
maybe college students like it but no
one else is gonna like it and
you know there's not gonna be any money
in doing this so all right so you only
really do it if you care
right if you're passionate about doing
it and then it started growing and
people said it would be a fad
and it would never be a good business
but you know you keep going because you
care
uh not because you're you're trying to
create a business um
and you know then there's the shift to
mobile where people thought
that it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and
um you know it through each of these
things
the entrepreneurs who i think build
things that last for a long time
keep going because they care
fundamentally about the change that
they're trying to create in the world
um and they're not in it just to build a
company
i built the first version of facebook
because it's something that
my friends and i wanted to use at
harvard a directory and a way to connect
with the other people
around us and i i didn't think at all
that it was going to be a company i
remember very specifically
the night that that we launched um the
first version i went out to
to get pizza with um a couple of my
friends who
um who now work here and you know and
i remember really clearly we were
talking about how one day
we thought that someone was going to
build a community like this for the
world
and that that would be some company but
like it clearly wasn't going to be us i
mean
it just it wasn't even it didn't even
occur yeah no i mean it wasn't even an
option that we considered that it might
be us i mean we just weren't focused on
building
a company back then we were just
building something that
that that we thought would be useful at
our school
with facebook there was just such you
know people loved it right
and had such an intensity of using it i
think within a couple of weeks
uh two-thirds of students at harvard
were using it and
all these other students at mit and
other local
universities were writing in asking us
if we could open up
uh facebook at their school so we kind
of just followed that right and you know
again we didn't i didn't set out and you
know my roommates didn't set out to
to build a service that we're going to
turn into a company but we just kind of
followed what people wanted and that
led us to expand it to all these other
schools and um
and eventually beyond schools and to you
know at some point
uh once we'd hired a bunch of people we
decided to turn it into a company and
and um and go for this mission of
connecting the world but that's not
where we started i always think that you
should start with
the problem that you're trying to solve
in the world and not start with
um deciding that you want to build a
company right the best companies that
that get built
are things that are trying to drive some
kind of social change even if it's
just local in one place uh you know more
than starting out because you want to
make a bunch of money or
have a lot of people working for you or
or build some company in some way so
you know i always think that this is
kind of a perverse thing about silicon
valley in a way
which is that you know people decide
often that they want to start a company
before they even decide what they want
to do
and that just feels really backwards to
me and you know for anyone who's had the
experience of actually building a
company
you know that you go through some really
hard things along the way and i think
part of what
gets you through that is believing in
what you're doing
and knowing that what you're doing is is
really
delivering a lot of value for people um
and and that's i think how the best
companies end up getting made i spent a
bunch of time analyzing and reflecting
on
why it was that we were even able to do
it because
all like all reasons suggest that we
shouldn't have been able
to do it right because all these other
companies had way more engineering power
and um and and servers and time and
money and all this stuff
and i actually think that this is a
pretty instructive thing for anything
that you want to go do
because this is the same property is
going to be true for anything that you
guys start is that someone else is going
to have more resources and be able to do
it
the reason why i think we actually ended
up being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else
right so there were always projects at
some of these other companies that were
these hobbies but we always thought that
it was this really important thing and
really just like felt in our gut in our
heart that we wanted to do it
and you know early on there were always
these skeptics saying that oh this can't
be a business we didn't actually care
that much about it being a business
early on
uh but a lot of the reason why bigger
companies didn't invest in it was
because it wasn't clear that there was a
model that would work for it it seemed
like a bad idea yeah and
i actually think that that's true for a
lot of the best ideas where it is that
it's not that someone else can't do it
they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you
but i think often that belief in the
fact that you just care so much about
what you're doing
is the only thing that kind of drives
you to do it and you know to be honest
that kind of drives me to this day i
mean one of the the big
emphasis uh points for the company right
now is internet.org
and you know for a while we had this
rallying cry of can we connect a billion
people
um and you know when we started talking
about that we thought that was crazy
right it was way bigger than any service
in in the world that had been built and
you know it was
10 digits long right it's like you know
it just it felt crazy we'd never get to
that
but then the thing is as we started to
actually get closer to that
we took a step back and we're like all
right well our mission isn't actually to
get one in seven people in the world to
be connected it's we want to connect
everyone so
it's um it's a big issue that only
around a third of the people in the
world have access to the internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early facebook
we don't there's no business model
around this i mean all the people who
have all the money in the world i mean
it's not necessarily a fair thing
are already the people who are on
facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world
um but we just believe really strongly
it's like this is what we are here to do
um this is what our company cares about
i care about it the team cares about it
our culture cares about it so
we're just going to keep pushing on it
and i actually think a lot of the reason
why great stuff gets built is because
it's kind of irrational
at the time but so it kind of selects
for the people who care the most about
it doing it
first of all focus on it right i mean i
think like you basically get what you
spend your time doing right i mean i
want the company to build
three products this year and we're gonna
work on a few others because people are
interested in them
but those are the three things that i'm
spending my product time on right um
you get what you put into it um if you
spend a third of your time
trying to make the people around you
better through getting better people
mentoring getting them to be better
getting the best people in your
organization
you're known to more impactful roles and
i think over time that just accrues and
you get a better organization
there are a few kind of simple
heuristics i don't hire people who i
wouldn't work for myself
i think that's a really good heuristic
because everyone knows this like there's
the saying like
a players hire a players and b players
higher c
players which is like good people higher
good yeah um
and i don't think that that's that
informative right because i mean what
are you going to say like just someone
in your organization
better be a player you don't get to hire
people like i mean no i mean um
and i think a lot of the time the
problem is you don't actually know and
sometimes you're like
trying to figure out how good someone is
if you didn't think they were good you
wouldn't have hired them
but the heuristic of only hiring people
who you would work for
um tends to be pretty good i think
because then it's like then that you
know right it's like i would not work
for this person then okay i'm not gonna
like
stretch just because i need to fill a
role today there's this culture in
silicon valley that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting
a startup and my goal
when i realized that i had a company was
to get it to be
a good company as quickly as possible
right and kind of get out of what you'd
call the like risky
startup phase where you are just like
constantly about to die
and where you could get to a point where
you can actually do some interesting
things and make make a lot more
interesting bets
and um so i don't know i i never read a
lot of the literature on this and i mean
maybe if i had then i wouldn't have made
so many mistakes
but so i don't know if like if learning
for me is the right way to go on this
but
i mean but it did i think your model
must have come from somewhere though
even if it was
even if you it was unintentional right
like were you influenced by peter thiel
or sean yes i was people seeing all
these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before
i'm talking about yeah right yeah but he
was massively influential on my thinking
right i mean
like a lot of the uh the early lessons
that i took
on how to think about strategy came from
peter and sean
and um i did pay a lot of attention when
i was growing up to microsoft i thought
i mean i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and in that
sense they are
yeah they really were awesome right um
well i don't know if you you meant that
positive positively but
i did and and i thought you know
building this ecosystem was really neat
and that kind of inspired me right
in the way that they built a platform i
kind of thought okay well maybe one day
you know the tools that i'm building can
be part of a broader ecosystem as well
one of the things that i think we've
done well is
is just given the people at the company
a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when i was 19 and and now
you know i'm running this big company
there were a number of people who joined
who were you know people i did problem
sets with at harvard or they dropped out
of stanford or
you know different programs who have
grown with the company over this long
period of time and
you know one of the things that i'm the
most proud of is we have
about 12 different product groups of the
company and
all of the people who are running them
um
with the exception of uh one uh
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me
that's amazing um and the one exception
was is david marcus who was the ceo of
uh
you know 50 billion dollar public
company so um you know so i'm pretty
happy that
that that he's on board and and having
him run a product group i think is a
pretty big coup too
but literally none of them started off
reporting to me um you know they all
start off in different
different roles some were engineers some
were data analysts
some were product managers and they've
all grown but i think what happens is
you know people see that you create
opportunities for people and
and that also i think keeps the best
people engaged and makes the best people
want to come work at your company
because they feel like oh i'm going to
get those kind of opportunities too
when you first launched in the very
beginning the features were sort of
profile with like a profile photo and
your name and who you are
and also you included things like what
house you lived in
um what dorm you lived in um and what
courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've
so we've dropped some of those things
but i remember um there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
at
and in order to do that we basically
went through and we parsed the course
catalogs of the schools to make sure
that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity
but it would be easier to launch new
schools if
we didn't have to have course catalogs
for each school and we just had this
really long debate about what quality
meant for us and the the community that
we wanted to establish and
and the culture of it and um you know in
retrospect you know maybe it wouldn't
have had a
huge difference on on how things played
out but it definitely kind of set this
tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook
you can rely on it it feels like a
college specific thing
yeah which was valuable early on for
setting the culture even though
obviously since then we've grown beyond
that
and you know i mean i think you guys in
the projects that you work on you're
gonna have a lot of
similar questions right i mean there's
the famous 80 20 rule where you know you
get 80
of the benefit by doing 20 of the work
uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish
this kind of quality bar and have your
product be the best thing that's out
there so
you know whether we had to do that one
or had to do something we had to do i
think enough of those things or else we
just wouldn't have been the best service
out there
the students around me were really
important as well right and
um both in high school
and in college i mean the people who
started facebook with me and a lot of
people who are still with me running the
company today
are people who i met when i was at
harvard and um some of them were my tfs
at harvard right and
you know when the professors were off
writing papers um
these were the people who actually
taught me and then we hung out and we
had like social bonds
and um academic bonds and um i just i
wouldn't understate the importance of
that and i mean
it's very tied into my whole philosophy
and
the product that i spend my life
building facebook because
um we just believe that social bonds are
critical
and um and one way that i think about
the
the value that facebook is filling in
the world is that you know you go
through school
and at least when i did people just
focused on
you know academics like achievement
different areas and
one of the things that no one really
ever taught me was like having friends
is really valuable
no not that i didn't have friends but
but like um
although you know the movie yeah i could
see that um
but that first girlfriend for sure i
don't think anyone is like
it's not like okay third grade we're
gonna like now we're gonna like teach
you
that like hanging out with people is a
very important
development right and i don't know i
actually think that that is
and um i think that's part of the reason
why sometimes people view facebook as a
waste of time but i actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and
i know that i wouldn't be where i where
i am today without
that aspect of my life being as
developed as the academic part
there's probably stuff you can say about
some insight that you had early on and
you thought to yourself
nobody else knows this except us but we
have this we have this great
this great trick do you remember any of
them
well peter thiel was really focused on
network effects
and he had this model that i think is
right
for making decisions that as the
complexity of the company grows
every day you're going to be faced with
100 things that you could potentially go
do and your job is to pick the one thing
that actually matters
because out of those hundred things it's
really only actually going to be one or
two things that actually matter
and that was pretty informative to me at
the time because
i had intuitively like i had a lot of
um some self-direction intuitively but
as soon as i started getting all these
people around me
um who all had reasonable perspectives
on things was very hard for me to
balance that and
peter was always very useful for for
that um
he was good at saying here's the one
thing that matters like focus on the one
thing that matters well partially
that and partially just the meta lesson
of figure out the one thing that matters
and do that but
do you remember what the one thing that
mattered like someone connecting
everyone as quickly as possible
because i mean network effects were a
massively important part of this one of
the the story so when you say connecting
everyone as quickly as possible you
don't mean specifically getting more
signups
you mean getting people to friend one
another faster yeah well how did you do
that
um well we built a lot of tools to
enable people to do what they
already wanted to where you can't like
push up hill on this stuff right
it's um we were solving a problem that
people had and we just needed to remove
as much friction as possible
there's this inherent conflict in the
system though which is you know are we
trying to optimize news feed to give
each person all of you guys the best
experience when you're reading
or are we trying to help businesses just
reach as many people as possible
and in every decision that we make we
optimize for the first
for making it so that when for the the
people um who we serve who use facebook
and who are reading news feed
get the very best experience that they
can and that means that if a business is
sharing content that's going to be
useful for them
then we'll show that but that means that
if the business is sharing content that
isn't going to be useful for them
we may not show that because it's
probably more important that they learn
about their friend who had a baby and
their baby is healthy
so that's an important guiding principle
for how we think about this stuff
and as the um and as the products
continue to develop there's just going
to be
more people sharing more things um and
we're going to continue to try to do our
best at
showing the best things that we can
understanding that there's no way that
we can
that a person will ever take the time to
go through every one of the 1500 things
um that are shared with them every
single day um so that's
but that's kind of how i think about
organic reach and um
you know there are a lot of pages that
are going that are doing quite
successfully and their organic reach is
is growing quite a bit because
they're delivering content to people
that they really want um so if you're a
business owner and you're thinking about
how to use
your free page on facebook i would just
focus on trying to
publish really good content that's going
to be compelling to your customers and
the people who are following you
ideas don't come out fully formed
they only become clear as you work on
them
you just have to get started
if i had to know everything about
connecting people before i got started
i never would have built facebook
movies and pop culture just get this all
wrong
the idea of a single eureka moment is a
dangerous lie
it makes us feel inadequate because we
feel like we haven't had ours yet
and it prevents people with seeds of
good ideas from ever getting started in
the first place
oh and you know what else movies get
wrong about innovation
no one writes math formulas on glass
okay
all right that's not a thing okay
it's really good to be idealistic
but be prepared to be misunderstood
anyone working on a big vision is going
to get called crazy
even if you end up right anyone taking
on a complex problem
is going to get blamed for not fully
understanding it even though it's
impossible to know everything up front
anyone taking initiative will always get
criticized for moving too fast
because there's always someone who wants
to slow you down
i always kind of like i get a little
upset whenever
any media attention focuses on me
personally
and me leaving facebook much less a
it's movie it's been kind of a bad year
hasn't it
it turned out okay time academy it
turned out it turned it turned out great
the time thing was awesome
um the um that was those really
flattering but like
but i think that it's one of these
things that the media systematically
gets
wrong is that this idea that it's a
person right it's never a person
right it's always a team and the most
important thing if you
are an entrepreneur trying to build
something is you need to build a really
good team
and that's what i spend a lot of my time
on right i mean i spend um
probably at least three hours a day with
our core team
right at doing things i spend probably
25 percent of my time recruiting finding
good people
both outside the company and inside the
company to put in more
and more impactful roles the hardest
thing for me early on
was you know because i i just started
off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on
on everything from architecture to
product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and i think it's really easy
when you start building something to
um to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so
you know most of my mistakes early on in
building the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this
very famous episode where
where like in 2006 a couple years into
building the company
um yahoo tried to buy us and
so they offered a ton of money and
a lot of the people who who i'd hired at
the point they were kind of experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they joined and then
you know within you know a year or a few
months like the the company had the
opportunity to exit for this
large amount of money and you know i
really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for and
in the absence of that that context
then of course it was a rational thing
for people to think that this was like a
good outcome for us to have
we've had this tradition for i don't
know probably
seven or eight years at the company
where every week
we have a q a where um where our
employees can come and ask me any
question
that they want about what's going on and
um what the what the direction of the
company is or
questions or things that they read about
in the press or that their friends who
use the product
um what what they're asking them and um
and it's been this really important
tradition for us
both because we really believe in an
openness and communication and that's
kind of what facebook is all about
uh but it's also really important for
for me
and for um running the company to be
able to get feedback
right and and to be able to learn what's
on people's minds
what are what our employees and folks
who who are
who are part of our team are thinking
about and um and just kind of
a lot of the time there are good
questions that people ask that change
the way that we
that we think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
and um that often make us go think and
reevaluate
how we should be approaching different
problems how have you hired your team
uh and what do you look for when you
bring people on
if you think about it you know i started
the company when i was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important
right or else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself
right and and and the company so you
know we
invest in in people who we think are
just
really talented even if they haven't
done that thing before
and you know that applies to people who
are fresh out of university
as well as you know people like um you
know the cfo who took the company public
and not taken a company public before
right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production
uh development at genentech before so
you know just
focus on really talented people no
matter what you do
you're gonna make a ton of mistakes
right and
i made it every mistake i think you can
probably make i mean
mistakes and how to set up the company
mistakes in hiring product mistakes
technical mistakes
um anything you can you can kind of
think about doing wrong
um i have probably made that mistake um
in in trying to kind of build facebook
up right i mean and it kind of makes i
was a college student when i got started
right i mean i didn't
know anything about business or hiring
you know no one was born with these
skills
right so you learn them the same way
that you learn uh
everything else right trial and error
you you do it uh you
don't be too afraid to make mistakes and
you do make mistakes
and you recover and you keep going the
the thing that i think
is really what you should focus on is
not what is the mistake that you should
avoid
but instead if you do something good
you get the strength to power through a
lot of mistakes
the main thing is just when you're
starting something it's um
it's just kind of hard you need to be
pretty headstrong about it right they're
going to be all these challenges that
come up
and i think the main thing that you need
to do is just not give up right and
um and kind of know what you want to do
and you know the best entrepreneurs that
who i've met
don't really start companies because
their goal is to build a company
they do it because they want to make a
change in the world and help people and
i think if you
if you kind of stay true to that and um
and if you
just focus on kind of powering through
no matter what the the challenges are
that will inevitably
come up in your path then um you'll find
that there are lots of tools that are
available and a lot of people who will
help you build what you're building
one definition that i have for uh a good
team
is a group of people that makes better
decisions as a whole
than it would individually make is a sum
of the parts and um when you're
i think most smart people like learning
right and i mean that's like one of the
thrills of starting a company right is
you're just
the learning curve can be so steep and
um if you can set up a team dynamic
where you're constantly learning from
the people around you then i mean what's
better
right so these are the people i wake up
every morning and i wanna i wanna go
learn from and work from
is that one of your heuristics for
hiring people too to like hire people
that you learn from
yeah and when building a team you want
it to
you want to think about the dynamics so
that way you can maintain this property
that the team makes better decisions
as a group than any individual would
today i want to talk about
purpose but i'm not here to give you the
standard commencement about finding your
purpose
we're millennials we try to do that
instinctively
instead i'm here to tell you that
finding your purpose
isn't enough the challenge for our
generation
is to create a world where everyone has
a sense of purpose
one of my favorite stories is when jfk
went to go visit the nasa space center
and he
saw a janitor holding a broom and he
asked him what he was doing and the
janitor replied
mr president i'm helping put a man on
the moon
purpose is that feeling that you
are a part of something bigger than
yourself that you are needed
and that you have something better ahead
to work for
purpose is what creates true happiness i
remember that night i launched facebook
from
that little dorm in kirkland house
i went to knocks with my friend kx
and i remember telling him clearly that
i was excited to help connect the
harvard community but one day someone
would connect the whole world
the thing is it never even occurred to
me that that someone might be us
we were just college kids we didn't know
anything about that
there were all these great big
technology companies with all these
resources and i just assumed one of them
would do it
but this idea was so clear to us that
all
people want to connect so we just kept
working on it day
after day after day and i know that a
lot of you are going to have your own
stories just like this
a change in the world that seems so
clear
that you are sure someone else is going
to do it
but they're not you will
but it's not enough to have that purpose
yourself
you also have to create a sense of
purpose for others
now maybe you're asking yourself can
i really do this
well remember when i told you about that
class i taught at the boys and girls
club
one day after class i was talking to my
students about
going to college and one of my top
students raised his hand and said
that he wasn't sure he could go to
college because he's undocumented
he wasn't sure if they'd take him
last year i took him out to breakfast
for his birthday
and i wanted to get him a gift so i
asked him what he wanted and
he just started talking about struggles
that he saw
other students in his class facing and
finally said you know i'd really just
like a book on social justice
i was blown away
here is a young guy who has every reason
to be cynical he wasn't sure
if the country he calls home the only
one he's known
was going to deny him his dream of going
to college
but he wasn't feeling sorry for himself
he wasn't even thinking
of himself he has a greater sense of
purpose
and he's going to bring people along
with him
it says something about our situation
today that i can't even say his name
because i don't want to put him at risk
but if a high school senior who doesn't
know what the future holds for him
can do his part to move the world
forward then we
owe it to the world to do our part too
there are probably a lot of people who
can who can run microsoft and do a
reasonable job
when i was growing up bill gates was my
my hero oh come on
yes he's like darth vader he's not he's
not luke skywalker
he's the bad guy no he is not um bill
gates
ran one of the most mission-driven
companies that i can think of
right and you know right now i think
microsoft their mission is less focused
than it used to be
but when i was thinking about you know
what would i want it to be
when when i grew up you know microsoft i
thought had had a great mission
put a computer on on every desktop and
in every office right or maybe it was
every desktop in every home
but and you know i mean there are
companies that define themselves by a
way of doing things right and there's
um them like the hp way that i was
talking about and there are companies
that define themselves by making a
concrete change in the world
and um you know microsoft did that
and i like i have a huge amount of
respect for for him for doing that he
pushed them and
it was an incredibly inspiring company
um during the time that he was doing
that i think that they're
they still are doing a lot of things but
i think that they've lost some of the
focus
and um i don't know i mean i think he's
like one of the one of the greatest
visionaries that our that our industry
has ever had
i remember distinctly i had this one
friend um
who i i went and got pizza with almost
every night we did all our computer
science problem sets together
at harvard and at the time i remember
talking to him about
how i was working on this facebook thing
and i thought it would be cool
for harvard and i really was excited
about it because i wanted to use it
but at the same time how i thought that
over time someone would definitely go
build this
version of this for the world but it
wasn't going to be us it was going to be
you know microsoft or you know someone
who built
software for hundreds of millions of
people it's like who we were college
students right we're not
qualified in any way to build this and i
think a lot of my takeaway from that was
that
we just kind of cared more than those
other companies about making it exist
the first set of schools that we
launched at after harvard
were schools that had other kind of
school specific social networks so i
think it was
stanford had something colombia had
something
and i think yale had something so i
think why did you choose ones that had
school specific social networks because
i wanted to competitors
well i wanted to go to the schools i
thought would be the hardest for us to
succeed at because i knew that if we had
a product that was better than
everything else that other students were
making at other colleges then it would
be worth investing in and putting and
putting time into but i didn't want to
just kind of
like get into a project where there
would end up being this huge legacy of
maintaining it if
ultimately there were just going to be
different things that were as good as it
companies are learning
organisms and you can make decisions
that either make it's that you learn
faster or you learn slower and
you know in a lot of ways building a
company is like following the scientific
method right you try
a bunch of different hypotheses and if
you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
again that's that's an important
philosophy so there are all these
different decisions that we make inside
the company
you know everything down to um really
empowering individual engineers
we invest in this huge um testing
framework right at any given point in
time there aren't
there's not just one version of facebook
running in the world right there's
probably tens of thousands of versions
running because
engineers here have the power to um to
try out an idea
and and and ship it to you know maybe
10 000 people or 100 000 people and then
they get a readout on how
that version of what they did whether it
was a change to
you know show better content to news
feed or or ui change or some new feature
they get a readout on how that version
performed compared to
the baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how
how connected people are um you know how
much people are sharing and how much
they
say that they're finding meaningful
content uh business metrics like how
much revenue we make and engagement of
the overall community
and you know by running tens of
thousands of different
experiments and putting the power in
people's hands to try all these
different things
you can imagine we just make so much
more progress than we could if every
change had to be approved by me
right or any every idea had to come from
from management so
i do think there's something very deep
about building this you know learning
culture
and moving quickly towards that that
just helps you get ahead over time
so many things go wrong when you're
starting a company and often i think
people
ask you know what mistakes should you
avoid making
and you know my answer to that question
is don't even bother trying to avoid
mistakes because you're going to make
tons of mistakes
right and the the um the important thing
is actually learning quickly
from whatever mistakes you make and not
giving up right and
i mean there are things every single
year of facebook's existence that could
have killed us or made it so that
it just seemed like moving forward and
making a lot of progress just seemed
intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of
keep running through the walls if we've
given the world a voice
look at what's happened in the last year
you've had elections in the last years
elections manipulated hate speech that's
gone viral and turned offline
it certainly seems like this mission has
been accomplished in many ways and and
there's a whole new set of problems that
perhaps you guys didn't foresee um
and now we're in a very complicated
place where there's not an easy solution
yeah there's these are complex issues
that you can't
fix you manage them on an ongoing basis
but
look do you think that the world is
better with everyone having a voice and
having the ability to express their
opinion
and being able to connect to who they
want i don't think we're going back to a
world where
there were just a handful of gatekeepers
who got to control what ideas get
expressed
and even if we could well i'm trying to
make it so we're not i mean that's why
um making it so that we're building
these independent governance mechanisms
and things like that are really
important and that's that's work that i
that i really care about um but i think
that the world will keep on moving in
this direction
people will more people will keep on
getting a voice uh
i think that that's good and and and i
think
there are certainly going to be issues
that we need to work through over time
but i think that while we are doing that
we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well
not just in terms of communities and
people being able to to connect with
with groups that are really meaningful
to them whether it's around a disease or
um or a community around veterans that
they wouldn't be able to connect to
otherwise
but even if you just think about the
economic impact of what we're doing
um you know we serve 80 million small
businesses
around the world about half of them have
told us that they're hiring people
because of using our tools and that
without facebook and the tools that we
that we provide um that they that their
business would be significantly smaller
and they wouldn't be hiring as many
people as they are
so you know a study came out the u.s
economy added about four and a half
million jobs over the last year
if you just look at like what people are
telling us the small businesses who use
our tools
we've directly been able to contribute
to creating many more jobs than that
across the world
so i think that this is the power of
giving people a voice
giving small businesses giving
communities giving everyone everywhere
the ability to connect with the people
who who they care about and get their
opinion across
and giving everyday people the power
that previously only big companies would
have had
so that's it the world is going to go
more in that direction
and i think by and large that's a good
thing so i'm really proud of the work
that we're doing on this and
we there are big issues and i'm not
trying to to say that there aren't that
we need to work through
but i i do think that sometimes you can
you can get the flavor
from a lot of this from from some of the
coverage that
um that's all there is and um and i
don't think that that's right either we
need to make sure that we address these
these questions these are really big and
important things for the future of our
society and the future of the internet
but we also need to keep pushing in the
direction of empowering more people
in a world that's changing so quickly
the biggest risk you can take is not
taking any risk
and i really think that that's true
right i mean a lot of people i think
think that
um you know whenever it comes to
whenever you get yourself into a
position where you have to
make some some big shift and direction
or do something
um you know they're always people are
going to point to the the downside risks
of that decision
and locally they're maybe right
right i mean if for any given decision
that you're gonna make there's
upside and downside but in aggregate if
you
are stagnant and you don't make those
changes then um
then i think you're guaranteed to fail
right and not not catch up so
to some degree i think it's really right
that over time the biggest risk that you
can
take is to not take any risks it wasn't
so
so long ago that you know i was a
student
and you know sitting in a seat in an
auditorium like
uh you guys are here today listening to
i remember very specifically this time
when bill gates came to talk it
at harvard and i'm just like wow
how do you how do you do that um and
um but you know the trick
is is that the media likes to
sensationalize this
as if you have some eureka moment or
you are some singular person who
can't build something on your own and
that's just not how the world works
um you know when i was in school i built
a lot of stuff that i just liked
building there was not a single moment
when i when i had some revelation that
facebook was going to be
awesome that's not maybe how the media
or movies or whatever would like to
portray things it's not it's much less
exciting but
the reality is i think most uh
services in the world that reach the
scale that facebook has
um you start off building something that
you care about and
you know you don't necessarily think
it's going to be that big
i didn't you know i built facebook the
first version of facebook
for my college community because i
wanted to be able to connect with the
people at my school
and i remember very clearly talking to
my friends
at the time and saying you know it's how
cool is it that we have built this
community for our school
you know one day it's going to be
awesome when somebody else builds this
for the world because something like
this needs to exist for the world but
it didn't even occur to me that you know
my friends and i might
be able to play a role in doing that
right because we were college students
right i mean we didn't
have any you know engineers to to work
with or
servers or resources or anything like
that and you know there are these
huge companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people right
there's
you know i always assume that it was
going to be like microsoft or google or
someone would build this for the world
and what basically just happened is
um at each step along the way we just
kind of kept
doing the next thing and uh growing from
there
and you know there were teams inside
these other companies that
that thought social media was important
and we're working on it but
you know there were all these different
memes and narratives uh
in the world you know people would say
oh well you know this is just a fad
people are going to use it but then
they're going to stop
so um you know so a lot of the teams
were working on didn't take it that
seriously
or you know the higher-ups and those
companies didn't care so they didn't get
resources and
we just kept going and going and then
people would say all right well
all right fine so maybe people are using
it but it's never gonna make any money
right i mean social media doesn't make
any money
then we just kind of kept going and
going and then pretty soon we had a
service that was
uh bigger than any of these other ones
and that kind of
is how we are here where we are um
there's no magic a lot of times i think
people just get afraid
because you know often your dream is
it's it seems like it's so
um so far off but but if you just kind
of focus on building stuff that you
think is good and
uh and and you keep on going at each
step along the way and don't let people
deter you from that and
you just really care about what you're
doing and kind of don't give up but each
step along the way then
um you know i think that's how you
that's how you build something good
throughout building facebook i mean
there have been lots of
challenges and there are all these times
where in anything you do where you know
you're really going to be pushed and you
feel like you want to give up or
something like that and you know this
gets back to
i was talking a second ago about how i
think the media
there's a little bit of this cultural
bias towards thinking that
you know one person does this right i
mean people say that
you know i built facebook or steve jobs
built apple or whatever but
you know that's really not true right i
mean it's we're
we're people we we helped but there were
thousands and thousands of other people
involved in building these things
and the reality is is that as strong as
any one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them
in anything that you do and one of the
ways that i think we maintain resilience
is by having um co-founders and partners
who complement our strengths and fortify
our weaknesses and
can kind of encourage us and give us a
push to to keep going when things are
tough
and there's actually a lot of data on
this that suggests that
companies that get started with more
co-founders
are more likely to be successful and it
isn't quite clear
exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear
in terms of the outcome for the startups
that it is the case
but i would guess that the reason why
that's the case
is because of this resilience point
where people who start something by
themselves
i i just think like there's no way that
any one person
can overcome all of the different things
that you need to do to to build
a startup or take on any kind of other
project in the world but if you have two
or three or four partners then i don't
know i mean maybe over time
one of them doesn't like it and drops
out but
you still have enough strength on the
team to power through all the challenges
that you have and
that's kind of how you go what we're
doing today
very similarly to how i thought about
where we were at the beginning
you know it's uh you know i get people
all the time who come to me and say all
right well
you're investing billions of dollars in
trying to uh
put internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
um it's not something that uh will that
we'll make any money from for a very
long
period of time if it works out but you
know it's this deep belief
that you're trying to make a change
you're trying to connect people in the
world
and i really do believe that if you do
something good and if you
help people out then eventually some
portion of that good
will come back to you and you may not
know up front what it's going to be
but that's just been the guiding
principle for me
in the work that we've done facebook is
a for-profit company why call it dot org
is this a non-profit is this charity
you know if we were primarily focused on
profits
the the most reasonable thing for us to
do
would be to really just focus on the
first billion people who are using our
products i mean the world isn't
set up equally and you know the first
billion
people are using facebook um have way
more money than the rest of the world
combined
so from a business perspective it
actually doesn't make a huge amount of
sense for us to put the emphasis in this
that we are right now
the reason why we're doing it is two
things one is mission
right i mean we're here to help connect
the world and we take that really
seriously and
you know you to some degree you can't
really do that if two-thirds of the
world doesn't even have access to the
internet so
you know we just turned 10 as a company
and
we decided that in our next 10 years we
want to take on some really big
challenges in the world like helping
everyone get online and
that's just an important thing for for
us and i think for a lot of other
internet companies and fulfilling this
mission overall
now over the long term i do think it
could be good for for our company as
well
if you look at it in a 10 20 30 year
time horizon
because a lot of these countries and
economies will develop and over time
they will be important
getting transparency inside a company is
really critical
but if the people running the company
don't have a sense of what all of the
people around the company are worried
about
um then you're not gonna be able to run
the company as best as possible and
that's why i do things like
every week i run a an open q a
and it's that way anyone can come and
ask me any question but it's not only
that
we try to make it so that we encourage
people to ask the hardest possible
questions
we create a poll in advance and people
can submit questions and people can vote
on them and they can do that anonymously
so that way uh we're i can make sure
every week
that i know what the top issues are that
people are worried about inside the
company
and that i can address that and we
certainly have a pretty flat management
culture we're not
generally very hierarchical you know i
talk to a lot of
my product managers and engineers and
just go through many layers of
management because i want to hear what's
going on and
that's just that's how we try to operate
the company and i think that's very
important
here's the thing it it wasn't so so long
ago
that you know i was a student and you
know sitting in a seat in an auditorium
like
uh you guys are here today listening to
i remember very specifically this time
when bill gates came to talk
it at harvard and i'm
just like wow how do you how do you do
that um
and um but
you know the trick is is that the media
likes to sensationalize this
as if you have some eureka moment
or you are some singular person
who can't build something on your own
and that's just not how the world works
um you know when i was in school i built
a lot of stuff that i just liked
building
there was not a single moment
when i when i had some revelation that
facebook was going to be
awesome that's not maybe how the media
or movies or whatever would like to
portray things it's not it's much less
exciting but
the reality is i think most
services in the world that reach the
scale that facebook has
um you start off building something that
you care about and
you know you don't necessarily think
it's going to be that big
i i didn't um you know i built facebook
the first version of facebook
for my college community because i
wanted to be able to connect with the
people at my school
and i remember very clearly talking to
my friends
at the time and saying you know it's how
cool is it that we have built this
community for our school
you know one day it's going to be
awesome when somebody else builds this
for the world because something like
this needs to exist for the world but
it didn't even occur to me that you know
my friends and i might
be able to play a role in doing that
right because we were college students
right i mean we didn't
have any you know engineers to to work
with
or servers or resources or anything like
that and you know there are these
huge companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people right
there's
you know i always assume that it was
going to be like microsoft or google or
someone would build this for the world
and what basically just happened is
um at each step along the way we just
kind of kept
doing the next thing and growing from
there
and you know there were teams inside
these other companies that
that thought social media was important
and were working on it but
there were all these different memes and
narratives uh
in the world you know people would say
oh well you know this is just a fad
people are going to use it but then
they're going to stop so um
you know so a lot of the teams were
working on didn't take it that seriously
or
you know the higher-ups and those
companies didn't care so they didn't get
resources and
we just kept going and going and then
people would say all right well
all right fine so maybe people are using
it but it's never going to make any
money right i mean social media doesn't
make any money and
we just kind of kept going and going and
then pretty soon we had a service that
was
uh bigger than any of these other ones
and that kind of
is how we are here where we are take me
inside mark zuckerberg's head to like
the moment that you decided
you needed to change facebook's core
mission was there an event that happened
or was there just a moment that you said
we got to change something well for most
of the last 10 years
this idea that the world should be more
connected
was not very controversial right and now
i think there are starting to be some
people who
question whether that is good so just
been this evolution where where for me
and for a lot of the people i work with
at facebook um
you know we feel like giving people a
voice is a really important thing to do
but
it's not enough to just give people a
voice you also have to you know help
build common ground
right so that way people can can move
forward together
and um and aren't just you know sharing
a lot of different opinions but you
actually have to help reconcile that so
that way
people can can come together as well and
you know that's a lot of
the responsibility that we feel now and
uh
and the mission that we want to take on
for the next 10 years of the company we
keep hearing we've never been more
divided we've never been more polarized
was it the political climate that that
led to kind of this awakening
i think it's really this feeling that
simply connecting the world
is not enough by itself that you also
have to work
and do proactive work to help bring
people closer together right so
you need to give people a voice so we
can get a diversity of opinions out
there
but you also need to do work to help
build enough common ground so that way
we can make progress as a society
together right you want to help people
stay connected with the people they
already know and care about but you also
want to make it so people
get access to new people and new
perspectives too so we're going to keep
on doing everything that we were doing
before to connect friends and family and
and to help people share but now we also
want to help people build communities
right and other ways that they can
connect and and help people bond and
come together and spread tolerance and
a lot of the values that i think we all
want to see in the world when i was
growing up
you know one of the big things that i
think that the internet enables is is
for people to
connect with groups of people who who
share their real
values and interests and it wasn't
always like this right before the
internet you were
really tied to your physical location
uh and and i just think about how when i
was growing up
um you know i grew up in a town of about
10 000 people
and um you know there were only um
you know so many different clubs or
activities that you could do so i grew
up
like a lot of the other kids um playing
little league baseball
and and you know i i kind of think about
this in retrospect it's like i'm not
really into baseball i'm not really an
athlete so why did i play
little league when you know my real
passion was programming computers
and you know the reality was that
growing up there was no one else really
in my town who was into programming
computers so i didn't
have a peer group or a club that i could
do that it wasn't until i went to
boarding school
and then later college where i actually
was able to meet people who
were into the same things as i am and
now i think with the internet that's
starting to change right and now
you have the ability to not just be
tethered to your physical location
but to find people who have more niche
interests and
and different kind of subcultures and
communities on the internet which i
think is a really powerful thing
steve jobs cared a little bit too much
about how perfect the edges of some
polygon were right um what is it that
you care too much about
connecting everyone
no seriously if you think about i mean
it's like this aesthetic sense of the
world that i have
is that you can communities of people
can channel their energy to do great
things
and having connections between people is
the infrastructure for the world to do
that
and you know that's why at each step
along the way when there was always
all this uncertainty about you know
whether it would be profitable or
whether it would
make sense or be good or whatever to do
these things
um we always were doing it because we
just cared more
and i mean to this day i mean you could
you could say that that was a startup
thing
but it isn't because i'm now we're here
and we connect more than a billion
people but
i mean we're pouring tons of money and
resources into connecting people who
can't even afford internet access
right so i mean that's like there's no
way that that's going to be profitable
in the near term or
medium term but we're doing it because
we think it's the right thing to do and
over the long term i do think
that there's something there and it's
going to be fundamentally important for
the world and maybe we'll get rewarded
maybe not but we just really care
do you remember how much your first
server cost you said oh yeah no
eighty-five dollars
eighty-five dollars yeah no i and i
remember that because um that was the
gating factor for us launching new
schools i
i mean we had this philosophy from the
very beginning that we didn't wanna be
this project it wasn't even a company at
the very beginning but we didn't want to
be burning a lot of money right we
weren't planning on raising a lot of
money we didn't want to be
one of these things that raised a bunch
of money and you know was losing a bunch
of money and then decided that we'd
somehow pull it through at the end and
um so you know so 85 for the first
server put ads on the site and
the the ads at the beginning were uh we
just were running some kind of ad
network and
do you remember what the first ad was um
no i don't um i don't know
how did you get ads um this was
eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning
and um you know but basically i mean so
it was the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
um and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get
an ad network so that way we can we can
make more money but then whenever we had
more money we
rented another 85 a month server and we
kind of went from there
and um i don't know just it's just an
interesting way of seeing you never
spent money you didn't have in the
beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars is
you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were
they grew quickly and it was really hard
for them to scale and um you know the
fact that we could kind of go college by
college and
and kind of optimize the service and
make it more efficient and offer new
features but make sure that they worked
i think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who had never built
a company before we never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly
then facebook did grow quickly but i
think it took a year for us to get a
million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but
um and and i think it is but it wasn't
as quick as a lot of things grow today
and i think actually having that time
to bake it was really valuable for me
this is a story that
i haven't told publicly and very few
people know but
early on in in our history
uh when before things were really going
well and
we had hit a tough patch and a lot of
people wanted to buy facebook and
thought we should sell the company uh
i went and i and i saw one of my mentors
steve jobs
and he told me that in order to
reconnect with what i believed as the
mission of the company
i should visit this temple that he had
gone to
in india early on in his evolution of
thinking about what he wanted apple
and his vision of the future to be and
so i went and i traveled
uh for for almost a month and
seeing the the people seeing how
how people connected and having the
opportunity to
feel how much better the world could be
if if everyone had a stronger ability to
connect
reinforced for me the importance of of
what we were doing and that is something
that i've always remembered
over the last 10 years as we built
facebook
recently you shared in a press
conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked will you just share what
you meant by that
yeah i mean
look it's let's be real here i'm not i'm
not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've been
planning for this i'm excited about it
and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds
so i mean look when when i got started
with facebook i was 19.
and um and i there were so many parts
about building a company that i didn't
know right
i didn't i didn't know anything about
hiring or managing or building a company
and i certainly didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i mean i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
and you know my experience you know kind
of growing up and running the company is
you know went out talked about what we
did say some stupid things get called
out for it and get like
kind of go into a in into a shell right
and and
uh end up being really cautious about
how we
communicate so you know it kind of it
worked out okay for a while for the
company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well
i think in spite of the fact that we
were communicating quite poorly about
what we were doing but
broadly speaking for a long time the
basic approach was okay
let's try to not like do anything that's
going to be too offensive
right and we'll kind of explain what
we're doing in broad strokes and
talk about the mission of what we're
doing which is something that i really
believe in
helping to build community and and bring
people closer together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
um some of the principles that we
believe in that that um
that are increasingly controversial in
the world and
i just think that we for one don't have
that luxury anymore
um for two uh i i think that that kind
of led for a while to a sentiment
towards the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if
if you're not kind of out there standing
for things that uh that people care
about then
you know it's not possible for people to
feel that strongly about what you're
doing but
so now you know i i've just i've tried
to change our approach more recently
you know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this
speech around our principles around free
expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now
what do you think the three keys to your
success are well i think a lot of it
goes back to those values right i mean
the values often come from
the founder the person running the
company so i think i believe those
things probably the most strongly of of
people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right um
focus on impact and i think um
you know i think long-term focus is is a
really important part of this
and we've had a lot of opportunities to
optimize for the shorter term whether
it's
in selling the company or doing
different products that would have
benefited us in the short term but not
optimized for the long-term impact then
um
and i just think you know opportunities
like this don't come around
that often so when you get one i feel
like you almost have a duty
to see it through and build it to be
what it can be we have a culture that's
very focused on
um being very focused on what we're
building so focus is a really important
part of it
but it wasn't at google for a long time
now it seems to be in vogue so they may
be saying you know this the focus is
better
so but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come
and and add their ideas i mean some of
the best ideas throughout the the
company's evolution
that they have just been from just
places all throughout the company
whether it's an engineer
or you know someone on the the customer
support team or just
different uh just different areas around
the company so we've always had
these hackathons right that are
basically time that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's
basically an incubator for people to
prototype different ideas much in the
spirit of how facebook got founded
originally
the idea that you can build anything
good in a day or a couple of days right
and get a version of that running
um so you get it running you then test
it internally yeah
and then we can see and that helps us
shape the road map and what we want to
do in the future but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and
we don't want to run with a lot of
projects that we don't expect to launch
right so so we want to get a lot of
ideas help have those ideas shape where
we want to go
and then execute in a very focused way
on the stuff that we're going to do but
i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us
and one which i talked about before is
just moving fast right the whole company
is really optimized around someone
joining being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly iterate very quickly
on that
i turned down the software to sell the
company
um the management team
or a bunch of of pretty experienced
folks um but who
hadn't spent a lot of time working at
facebook weren't weren't that steeped in
in what we were trying to do
um you know the group basically fell
apart within within i think was 18
months after that
every single other person on the
management team either
quit or it was just so dysfunctional
that i had to fire them
and and most of them quit and
that was really challenging because i i
think i was like 22 at the time
so again it's like i was i just i hadn't
learned you know most of the lessons
that i
have learned to this point on on
managing um but
you know i kind of feel like when you
have internal team cohesion and you have
a team that believes in something
you can get a lot of things done and you
can handle a lot of adversity
but when you break that when that starts
to break down
um it becomes very hard to get things
done
and you know even so through the other
big challenges that we've had to
navigate over time
um you know not just the last couple of
years but um you know after we went
public where we had a big business model
challenge we were transitioning from
a desktop and web-based business to
mobile
um our app wasn't in in the space that i
wanted it to be we didn't have ads
in news feed yet so we weren't sure if
that was going to work um
we went public and our market cap got
cut in half in like
within the first year and and people
doubted whether we were going to be able
to make this transition to mobile and
you know empirically that's not a crazy
thing to doubt because a lot of
technology companies basically
die or really lose their weight during
these big technology shifts right so of
which
going from web to mobile was certainly
one um
but you know through that period we were
able to maintain very good team cohesion
internally everyone had a
strong sense of mission they knew what
we were there to do uh they believed in
the products
uh they cared about connecting people
and bringing the services to more people
around the world
um so it actually it didn't end up being
that that challenging of a period in the
grand scheme of things
um you know not that many people quit uh
people saw through the
the challenge that we needed to go that
we needed to go do and we came out of
that well
um but the internal team cohesion thing
is a really big deal
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
how do you sustain a business model in
which users don't pay for your service
senator we run ads
if i'm email if i'm mailing emailing
within whatsapp does that ever inform
your advertisers
no we don't see any of the content in
whatsapp it's fully encrypted
right but is there some algorithm that
spits out some information
to your ad platform and then let's say
i'm emailing about black panther
within whatsapp do i get a whatsapp do i
get a black panther
banner ad senator we don't
facebook systems do not see the content
of messages being transferred over
whatsoever yeah i know but that's that's
not what i'm asking i'm asking
about whether these systems talk to each
other without a human being touching it
senator i think the answer to your
specific question is if you message
someone about black panther and whatsapp
it would not inform
any ads okay there have been reports
that facebook can track
the user's internet browsing activity
even after that user has logged off
of the facebook platform can you confirm
whether or not
this is true um
senator i want to make sure i get this
accurate so it'll probably be better to
have
my team follow up you don't know um i
know that
people use cookies on the internet
and that you can probably correlate
activity between
between sessions we do that for a number
of reasons
including security and including
measuring ads to make sure that the ad
experiences are the most effective which
of course people can opt out of well
facebook offered to all of its users a
blanket opt-in
to share their privacy data with any
third-party users
[Music]
congresswoman yes that's how our
platform works you have to
opt-in to sign in to any app before you
use it could somebody call you up and
say
i want to see john kennedy's file
absolutely not could you if not
not could you not would you do it could
you do it
in theory do you have the right to put
my data a name on my data and share it
with somebody
i do not believe we have the right to do
that you have the ability
senator the data is in the system so you
have the ability
technically i think someone could do
that but that would be a massive breach
so we would never do that if you want to
sign up for the entire billionaire
mindset series for free and get the
companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there